Hey, guys, Dr. Berg here in this video I
want to introduce you to a new product I
just came out with called electrolyte
powder. Okay so what's unique about this
is that it doesn't have any sugar it
doesn't have any maltodextrin
it has a thousand milligrams of
potassium citrate that is very very safe
on your body and you hypothetically
could use this to enhance your potassium
if you're not consuming enough
vegetables you could even do three or
even four servings to reach your maximum
dosage of about 47 to 5,000 milligrams
but here it has the calcium potassium
magnesium chloride and sodium and trace
minerals 71 ionic trace minerals all in
one blend and it has a touch of stevia
with some natural flavorings of
raspberry and lemon so it tastes good
putting water dissolve it up drink it up
and it's used mainly to enhance your
exercise performance most electrolyte
powders have sugar and it lowers your
performance this is also great to
support a healthy cardiovascular
system and improve your energy so
there's four main things the
electrolytes do number one they help
your fluids they help hydrate you they
prevent from dehydration
they help fluid move it in and out of
the cell okay so they're great it's
great for like edema or swelling things
like that it's also supports the nervous
system so the nerves need electrolytes
for the rhythm that prevent palpitations
prevent tetany that's that little
twitching on the eye or a little or
throughout the body improve and help
balance the heart rate okay it's mainly
potassium helped influence the pH so
your pH is just correct
so the electrolytes and pH work together
if your electrolytes are off that can
throw off your ph if your pH is off that
can throw off your electrolytes and also
primarily it affects muscle physiology
the contraction and relaxation of the
muscle and then of course if you don't
have that you get cramps weakness or
spasm okay so I put a link down below to
get more information check it out and I
think I think you'd find this quite
helpful!